hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
as you're watching this you've probably
completed the story of Marvel's
spider-man but now you're chasing down
the platinum trophy and all the spider
suits on offer let me give you a hand
finding the 50 hidden photos which
unlock the BSU outfit if you have the
gadget which lets you see these spots be
sure to equip it it'll speed things up
no end but if not don't worry I've tried
to make this route as painless as
possible starting with 11 photos in
Haarlem the first one at the cemetery go
all the way north until you find Uncle
Ben's gravestone this is also the spot
to grab the trophy link to good old
Uncle Ben jump slightly south for photo
op number two in the shape of the church
continue south over the road and on the
rooftops is this piece of street art and
that's where jonah paid me the big bucks
over to the west is this buyer to
photograph nailed it travel south down
the shoreline until you spot this
graffiti magnifica continue south again
until you spot this building traveling
inland to the east just below Harry
station is the Harlem sanitarium stop it
head north towards the bridge to photo
the pale horse rides mud shop depending
on when you arrive this building may be
on fire web sling self to find Osborne's
electorial office who doesn't want that
in their fault welcome it'll be so much
easier if I have a giant robot just
asylum become Central Park you'll see
this statue each taking a picture of its
but is optional and Harlem's last secret
photo can be found east next to the
prisoner camp drop down to find this
greenhouse moving on to the upper east
side are far more photo opportunities
keep a look out for this place the black
wing tap I couldn't have been with great
power comes high continuing south this
spot take a photo of the water feature
I've got how much I love photography in
the bottom left corner of Upper East
Side is the library touting Greek
nice the last one in Upper East Side is
right on the border to Central Park
heads here to take a photo of the Latin
American Museum New Yorkers are so jaded
I remember when they used to scream in
terror at the sight of me Central Park
has far more photo ops that are easy to
find right in the center is this beast
check out my homepage it's on the web
get it close by is a castle very hard to
miss going south you'll see a small pond
or lake and this Shack next and up north
is this structure completely the Stars
and Stripes perfect over to Upper West
Side and first up snap a shot of the
Oscorp doors
Oscorp I've got my issues with that go
west to the Greenbelt to see this
building what you sell is another statue
and a little further south than that is
this monumental nailed it argued finally
east of Harry station is the fire
department snap the fire truck for our
2000 image we are going to Hell's
Kitchen next but the first one is once
again on the borderline with Central
Park take a pic of the statute perfect
go towards the piers until you spot a
skull and cross swords there's a keeper
back inland you're looking for
Daredevils office it's right next door
to a standard photo opportunity with
great power comes pride and the last one
in Hell's Kitchen is this mural of
vulture right at the bottom of the
district and that's where Jonah paid me
the big bucks we're now moving into
Midtown for photos 29 through 31 get
yourself near all the billboards but get
up high the photograph we want is of
this bell tower head north east to find
this tree somehow surviving in the urban
jungle traveling south you'll spot this
koi after feety it's not how much I love
photography over in Greenwich now in the
top-left corner is the modern art museum
Magnus
pick the side carelessly perhaps
something in a sassy robot heading east
you'll spot this LGBT black field
mopping this would all be so much easier
if I had a giant robot and the last
winning Greenwich is slap-bang in the
middle photograph this wall art of Jay
jonah Jameson come on stick with it
we're almost there let's jump into
Chinatown in the top-left corner
photograph of this statue head southeast
to see this movie poster bird and each
gallon close by is this municipal fool
gets shot by the bridge to the east is a
skate park perfect continue on this very
bridge West and photographed this
structure weird dream last near the
lower left corner is the police station
be sure to photo the door Yuri was a
detective at the Chinatown Police
Department when we met barely a few feet
away from the copshop is a back alley
with a mural of rhino magnifique the
last one we need in Chinatown is Leos
restaurant now on to the financial
district starting in the top right
corner you'll see this leprechaun thing
posing on a building go down to the main
street and you'll find this that's our
crocodile has a keeper over on the west
and on the pier itself is a bunch of
tennis courts to photograph wait hook
the shoreline cell for two pictures in
quick succession first is this thing
nice and just around the corner is a
flowered window to photograph nice
composition if I do say so myself
I need a catchphrase image 49 is the
boss statue which has been changed into
a dog from the Inhumans and the very
last one head to the bottom left of the
entire map and take a photo of the
Statue of Liberty now that's how you end
the video we've bloody done it check
your suit screen to wear your university
colors with pride Oh anyway I hope that
helps
I'm Adam from PlayStation granade been a
pleasure I'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]